do you really need AppleCare plus now
that Apple's coverage includes Unlimited
Repairs paying for an extended warranty
might seem like a good idea especially
if you've ever cracked one of these but
odds are most people won't need it let's
get into why it's usually not worth it
to pay hundreds of dollars to insure
your iPhone or your other Apple products
for that matter
apple is pushing a new plan for its
latest high-end phones the old plan
covered up to two incidents of
accidental damage per year now the new
plan covers unlimited incidents there's
a couple reasons you might think you
need coverage you might be scarred by an
experience that happened years ago when
you're dangling headphones couldn't save
your iPhone screen from cracking or
maybe your iPhone 6 never recovered from
that drop in the toilet I same time it's
expensive to replace a broken phone
especially now that a lot of high-end
models cost a thousand dollars or more
then they're the psychological elements
at play experts say our phones are so
important to us that we might just feel
the need to insure them just for peace
of mind but you may not realize what it
all costs until something goes wrong if
you need a screen replacement on a phone
like this under Apple Care Plus you're
paying 298 dollars using the Genius Bar
without Apple Care that'll cost you a
bit more third-party repairs may be
cheaper but if they don't use authorized
Parts you might forfeit Apple's limited
warranty self-repair is also an option
but the savings aren't great and most of
us wouldn't know how to safely perform
surgery on an iPhone anyway if you need
your whole phone replaced that's another
story with AppleCare Plus for an iPhone
14 pro Max you'll pay at most 418
dollars for a brand new phone and you
can do this twice under one plan you'll
end up saving if you end up breaking any
of these other Apple devices too
these numbers matter but what's most
important is really your odds of
actually breaking your iPhone all of
Apple's iPhone since the iPhone 7 have
dust and water resistance and screens
have stronger reinforced glass from one
generation to the next that higher
durability is one of the reasons
smartphone users overall are replacing
their phones less often most people
don't even break their smartphones and
many who do just live with the damage a
t says some people are way more likely
to break their smartphones than others
if you're under 35 years old if you have
kids if you're unemployed and if you
don't go to college you're among those
who break their phones the most often
you're also more likely to damage your
current phone if you broke your last one
and psychologists noted that when
smartphone makers push a new device and
you subconsciously know you want it you
become more careless and are more likely
to damage the one you already have
frankly even if you're not at higher
risk for breakage you should probably
just put a case on your iPhone when you
just examine how much you're saving if
your phone breaks AppleCare plus seems
like a good deal just know it's an even
better deal for Apple the company groups
AppleCare with other Apple services and
that business makes more and more money
each year experts say apple is likely
being generous with its repairs because
it knows most people won't need one
that's the nature of insurance your
phone may already have lost coverage if
you pay for renters or homeowners
insurance there's also third party
coverage available for a fraction of the
price when you have AppleCare plus you
really only benefit if you break your
phone and if not you've forked over
hundreds of dollars to Apple over years
for most of us that's a lot to pay for
peace of mind
[Music]